You have a great
idea for a new game.
But it really needs that big
screen in your living room
to come to life.
You could write
for a game console.
But then you'd lose all
those millions of people
with mobile phones.
What is a game developer to do?
With the new Google Cast
Remote Display APIs,
your app can now render
directly to any Cast receiver
like Chromecast.
Remote display is all about
combining the amazing rendering
capabilities of mobile devices
with the immersive power
of large TVs to create
compelling interactive content.
It extends the existing
Google Cast APIs,
which were previously only
focused on controlling HTML5
apps running on Cast receivers.
Remote display supports
both Android and iOS.
The APIs are different.
So I'm going to show you how
to integrate remote display
for each of them.
Before you start writing code,
take a step back and make sure
your design will work with
two very different screens.
The first screen is a remote TV.
This is where you'll
want to display
the main action of your game.
The second screen is a
smartphone or tablet screen.
Players don't spend
a lot of time looking
at it, which makes
it a great option
to display secondary information
like statistics, player
inventories, or
an in-game store.
You can also display
a virtual controller.
Finally, your game can either
require a second screen
or be optional.
Have a clear
description of what it
requires, both in the marketing
material, and in the game.
But enough about design.
Let's go over the Android APIs.
On Android, remote display
combines and extends
the media router,
presentation, and service APIs.
You'll use media router
for device discovery,
presentation as the container
for the first screen content,
and service to separate the
life cycle of the presentation
from that of your activity.
Let's go through each of these.
The media router
APIs let you discover
available Cast receivers.
Remote display
works the same way
as any other Castable
app in this respect.
And we have a great video
on the Google Developers
channel about discovery.
Check it out.
The presentation APIs
is Android's gateway
to other screens.
The remote display APIs provide
a specialized presentation
that your app must subclass
to, well, present your game
on the remote screen.
You can, in fact,
display any view
you want from a regular Android
layout to an OpenGLES surface.
Finally, the remote display APIs
provide a local Android service
to keep rendering even
while your main Android
activity is backgrounded.
This also makes it possible
to control your game
with a Bluetooth controller
while the mobile device sits
on the player's coffee table.
You may be asking
yourself, what about audio?
Well, you don't
have to do anything.
Remote display automatically
mirrors the device's audio when
your game is in the foreground.
All right, let's look
at the iOS APIs now.
On iOS, the remote display APIs
provide low-level functionality
to send video and audio to
the Cast receiver and services
to start a remote
display session.
There are four stages in a
life cycle of a remote display
session.
Connect, negotiate,
send, and stop.
Let's dive into the details.
The connect stage
includes discovering
as suitable Cast receiver,
connecting to it,
and launching your remote
display receiver app on it.
Like on Android, this
works exactly the same way
as for any other iOS
Cast-enabled app.
And like for Android,
we have a sweet video
on the Google Developers
channel about this process.
In the negotiation stage, use
the remote display channel
and configuration APIs to
offer session parameters
to the receiver.
If the receiver is
happy with the settings,
you'll have established
a remote display session.
It's finally time to render
it to that big screen.
In the send stage, your app
renders video and audio frames
to the remote display session.
Each app will integrate remote
display in a different way.
So I'll go over some
generic tips and tricks
that should help you.
For audio, the basic idea
is to redirect your game's
audio stream from the
system's audio device
to the remote display session.
Don't forget to silence
output to the device's
built-in speakers.
Otherwise your players
will feel like they're
in an echo chamber.
For video, create a
frame input object
matching you're rendering API.
Frame inputs are
adapters that make
it easy to integrate
your rendering
code with remote display.
The general flow is to render
to a texture instead of a system
surface.
Once you have your
remote display frame
encoded, hand over the
texture to the frame input
for processing.
And that's it.
After that you can
render a different frame
for the device's screen
as you would normally do.
OK, if you remembered
two minutes ago,
I said there were four stages.
The last one is stop.
And it's pretty easy.
To end a remote
display session you
just kill the remote
display receiver
app using the core Cast APIs.
That's it.
We are super excited to
see the amazing games
and experiences you will
build with Google Cast Remote
Display.
Don't forget to check
developers.google.com/cast
to get more information on
getting started with remote
display.
We also have complete sample
code available on GitHub.
Also check out the
game manager APIs,
which make writing multiplayer
games that run directly
on a Cast receiver super easy.
Thanks.